everybody loses last night's
presidential debates so Bernie remains
on top but the Oppo file on the
septuagenarian socialist is starting to
leak and a couple of Bernie's erotic
manifestos give us some insight on the
Sanders campaign we will examine the
eternal connection between creepy sex
and leftist politics then CNN redefines
newborn babies as fetuses that are born
and Bernie rebuffs the Obama era all
that and more on Michael Knowles and
this is the Michael Knowles show
[Music]
Bernie Sanders has some sick creepy
views about sex and it is by far the
most interesting aspect of his campaign
and it really matters it tells us a lot
about the left which we will get to in a
second but first I have got to quickly
cover what happened during last night's
presidential debate during last night's
debate I was on a plane as it was
landing the plane is landing as the
debates beginning I'm then running
through an airport to catch a layover
and then I am taking off and I'm doing
my best to listen because it was by far
the most wild crazy exciting democratic
debate so far they were all going after
one another and they all lost so South
Carolina is supposed to be Joe Biden's
big comeback that's why South Carolina
matters for the establishment of the
Democratic Party it's Joe Biden's
firewall he's been saying it from the
beginning he's got to win here it's the
first state with a large black voting
population that's where Joe does well
that's where Bernie tends to do poorly
it's where Budaj edge doesn't get a
single vote that's where Warren doesn't
do very well and so he's got to win this
right how is it looking
unfortunately for Joe Biden he spent
most of last night his last state in
South Carolina trying in vain to form an
English sentence the maybe the most
coherent part of last night it's
definitely in the top three was when Joe
Biden claimed that guns had murdered
half of the country in the last 13 years
that is caused carnage on our streets a
hundred and fifty million people have
been killed since 2007 when Bernie voted
to exempt the gun manufacturers from
liability 150 million people I'd think
that might be off by an order of
magnitude or two or three or that's
probably looking around I don't think
half of my countrymen have been murdered
in the last 13 years and sadly that was
maybe Joe's most coherent moment of the
night he spent much of the rest of the
debate just sort of incoherently
rambling he would randomly just stop
speaking so he'd be mid-sentence and
he'd say okay I'm gonna stop why did I
stop
I shouldn't no one else is stopping
anyway okay what's going on what's for
dessert what are we having and the line
II kept going back to which beyond the
apparent senility beyond the slowing
down or garbling his words the line is
really hurting him out there just for as
an ideological matter is he keep saying
I'm the only one that gets stuff done
there was the line he kept going back to
all night long I'm the only one who's
gotten anything done everybody's talking
about is the plan that I first
introduced that is to go and add to
Obamacare provide a public option a
Medicare like option if you're the only
one who's gotten things done if you've
gotten so much done why are there still
all these problems right if this is the
best you could do you've been in office
since the 70s you've gotten all these
things done why are there so many
problems Joe Biden goes out there
because I got health care done well if
you got health care done how come 87
million Americans are still uninsured
how come there's still this apparent
crisis of health care that all the
Democrats are telling us about remember
Obama care in 2008 was supposed to and
then 2009 when it actually goes through
we supposed to fix all of the health
care problems but it didn't it was
supposed to give us universal health
care it didn't it didn't work all it did
was raise the prices of health care and
force Americans unconstitutionally to
buy a product that they didn't want so
you got it done but there's still all
these problems he keeps going back to he
says I'm the only guy who's taking on
the NRA twice I beat the NRA well you
beat the NRA how come they stole all
these shootings now maybe here's here's
a reasonable answer to that the reason
they're still all these shootings is
because you don't stop crime by taking
away American civil rights may be the
reason why there are still issues with
health care is because the problem with
health care is not that there was too
little government it was that there was
too much government interference may
that just a suggestion
either way the solutions that Joe Biden
is proposing are pretty weak he doesn't
have credibility on this he's had 50
years to fix the problems and he hasn't
done it the second saddest performance
of the night came from a be Klobuchar
before we got into Bloomberg finally
making a comeback a little bit
to come back and then kind of a flop
we'll get into all that first I've got
to thank our friends over at AB sleep
you know me I need at least what 18 19
hours of sleep at night just to just to
maintain my beauty rest you need to try
AB sleep if you have tried everything
else from pills to pillows and you got
your thoughts racing all night long it's
time to try AB AB sleep is a wearable
solution that fits over the forehead and
gently and precisely cools the forehead
to reduce those racing thoughts it
allows people who suffer from
sleeplessness to drift more comfortably
into a deeper more restorative sleep
it's actually a fairly simple idea you
cool your head the studies have shown
this will slow those racing thoughts
help you fall asleep AB can do it it's a
really great way to deal with stress and
everybody is very stressed out brain
imaging studies followed by 3,800 nights
of clinical studies by renowned sleep
researchers revealed this revolutionary
way so right now have the energy to do
the things you love again by getting the
sleep that you need ABS natural solution
has no morning side effects let you get
back to peak performance right now our
listeners can try ab risk-free for 60
nights to confirm it's the solution
you've been looking for at tribe comm
slash NOLs that's t ry e BB dot-com /
Knowles Kino wles
tribe comm / Knowles order today to get
the sleep you need and deserve all right
the second saddest performance of the
night was amy klobuchar remember there
was Amy meant club mentum coming out of
New Hampshire because she finished like
what 7th or something and that was
supposed to be really exciting so Amy
Klobuchar are trying to grab that
moderate Lane from either Pete Budaj
edge or Liz Warren depending on the day
of the week but and this just it's just
not really working out that well last
question of the night was two parts last
question was what's the biggest
misconception about you and what is your
motto and amy klobuchar unintentionally
gave the funniest possible answer to
that say the biggest the biggest
misconception is that I'm boring because
I'm not
I would say that my motto is the words
of one of my political mentors Paul
Wellstone who sadly no longer with us
and he said that politics is about
improving people's lives the biggest
misconception about me is that I am
boring and my motto is politics is
political or something come on Amy yet I
like jazz it up a little bit if you just
say hey guys I'm not really boring then
you've got to say something that isn't
the most banal basic obvious statement
for your motto the other candidates
answers really were not much better Liz
Warren's was the absolute worst she's
she said the big misconception about me
is that I don't eat enough but I eat I
just happen to be so thin I look too
good oh what's my biggest weakness
employer I work too hard that's it
that's me whoopsy I know I really got to
work on that it's just so so pathetic
Warren actually to her credit did get a
couple shots in but the shots misfired
and her big line of the night she was
going for Mike Bloomberg went for the
jugular and there's a it's kind of an
interesting reason why she went for my
Bloomberg we'll get to that in a second
the line itself was so outrageous she
went after Bloomberg for a rumor that
Bloomberg once told a female employee of
his who had become pregnant that he
should quote kill it and she brought
this up as such a heinous awful terrible
thing to say at least I didn't have a
boss who said to me kill it the way that
I mare Bloomberg never read that I've
said to one of her pregnant employees
people want advance here this is the
most oblivious political attack I've
ever seen
just yesterday Elizabeth Warren voted
against a bill that would protect babies
who survived abortion and are born alive
she voted to deny medical care to
newborn babies if their mothers had
tried to kill them and then she attacks
Bloomberg for allegedly no evidence but
allegedly saying to a female employee
that she should go kill it kill what Liz
just a Columbus that you can't kill a
clump of cells it's just to feed us
right how on earth could you possibly
cuz it's a baby and it's bad that Mike
Bloomberg said that someone should kill
it but it's good that you voted to deny
medical care to the babies who didn't
manage to get killed is that that the
line okay very very strange logic there
now what the reason the warned was going
after Bloomberg last night and not after
Bernie is because her attack on Bernie
Sanders totally backfired so Elizabeth
Warren remember this whole campaign liya
Wafaa
right she doesn't know which way she's
gonna go is she gonna be the
establishment Tyrian moderate is she
gonna be the socialist radical what does
it depends on the focus groups depends
on how the polls are looking so right
now it looks like she's in the Bernie
Lane so she should go after Bernie
trouble is she went after Bernie last
time and it completely backfired so she
leaked that story about how Bernie said
a woman can't be elected president and
she called him out for it on the stage
and then it didn't work and her poll
numbers tanked so even though she's
still going for Bernie's voters she has
got to attack Bloomberg because she
knows that when she tacks Bloomberg her
poll numbers among the progressives go
up the problem for Warren is that she's
just so unlikable and she doesn't just
know how to respond she can throw the
first punch but then she doesn't know
how to react when people fight back so
for instance she gives this ridiculous
attack on what Bloomberg allegedly said
she builds that into attack about how
Bloomberg has had allegations of sexual
harassment at his
not against him but at his company in
the women who took a payout decided to
sign non-disclosure agreements and
that's terrible and the nba's are so bad
and then Bloomberg response he said okay
you think we should release women from
these non-disclosure agreements we did
that and now we've also decided as a
company not to have any more
non-disclosure agreements because you've
asked for that so we've done everything
you've asked what do you want and she's
left there sputtering because she
doesn't have an answer she just wants to
keep banging Bloomberg over the head
with that and it doesn't work she's
unlikable Bloomberg actually is likable
in some ways and he did much much better
at this debate than at the last one he
got a lot of good jabs in at the
different candidates and he's very good
at getting jabs in at Bernie he got one
jab in where he suggested that Vladimir
Putin is hoping that Bernie gets the
nomination so that Bernie loses to Trump
you respond to that do you think senator
Sanders economy would be better for
America than I think that Donald Trump
thinks it would be better if he's
president I do not think so
Vladimir Putin thinks that Donald Trump
is should be present United States and
that's why Russia is helping you get all
the ules
him
he's got a great dry delivery when he's
getting these jabs in at Bernie ya Putin
wants you to get the nomination cuz
you'll lose to trump or at the last
debate he said look Bernie you're a
socialist who was a millionaire with
three houses and then Bernie says well I
live in Washington I work in Washington
and Bloomberg goes yeah that's the first
problem
he's good like a New Yorker tends to be
he's good at getting these little jabs
and at people he's he still can't take
it all the way he's not like Trump where
he can entertain in a sort of broad
spectrum of show business
he's only got that one little lane is
that he can insult people Bloomberg so
he tried to make a self effacing joke
last night that did not go very well I
don't know which Hollywood scriptwriter
wrote this joke out for him but it did
not land Bloomberg tried to make a joke
about what a bad job he did at the last
debate and it just fell flat let me also
say because it just is since I have the
floor for a second that I really am
surprised that all of these my fellow
contestants up here I guess would be the
right word for it
given nobody pays attention to the clock
I'm surprised they show up because I
would have thought after I did such a
good job in beating them last week that
they'd be a little bit afraid to do that
hi yes I know that you asked me a
question but beep-boop I've been told by
my programmers to tell this
self-effacing joke ah
beep-boop beep-boop doesn't work just
didn't Lee was so awkward like please
stop this maybe you don't you don't need
to be self-effacing but you know if
you're gonna do it do it I don't I don't
know which staffer wrote that joke I
don't know which staffer told him by the
way his biggest flaw of the debate
performance which was that he defended
the government of China I mean this is
Bloomberg's problem Bloomberg who
actually has many good qualities he's a
very successful businessman very
pragmatic manager and able manager he's
very good at making markets more
efficient that kind of stuff he's just a
vision 'less technocrat that's the
problem and so he ends up at one point
he's asked about the government of China
and he ends up defending the Chinese
government which is a brutal government
you know the adviser who told him to do
that spore the same with
put his face on a meatball it's just it
doesn't resonate with the American
people and so he defends this tyrannical
government he's not the only candidate
by the way to defend tyrannical
governments but we'll get to Bernie in a
second because bernie is really the
winner ultimately of this debate and
bernie is a creepy creepy dude and
Bernie's revolution is going to be
pretty pervy so we'll get to that but
first I'm gonna talk to you about how
you got to make your neighborhood safer
and that is with ring.look I live in Los
Angeles a giant city not known for being
the safest city in the world just the
other day we had two guys break into our
building who were trying to steal
packages and I think they made away with
a number of packages luckily they didn't
make it to my door and if they had I
would have seen their faces because of a
ring ring just keeps you safer ring
helps you stay connected to your home
anywhere in the world you already know
about their smart video doorbells and
cameras that protect millions of people
everywhere ring helps you stay connected
whether you're in the office whether
you're in Washington DC like I am you'll
get an alert you'll be able to see hear
and speak to whoever's at the door maybe
it's a burglar maybe it's your
mother-in-law maybe you don't know which
one you would rather it was it look I
joke sometimes about how you can see
little crazy critters like little
opossums and things you can come infront
of the camera but also you can see when
people come by and try to rob you and
it's really really helpful as a
subscriber you get a special offer right
now in a ring welcome kit at ring.com
slash knowles canada wles the kit
includes a video doorbell in two chime
pro which is just what you need to start
building a ring of security around your
home today go-to ring comm slash Knolls
cana wles that's ring.com slash knowles
bloomberg wasn't the only guy to defend
tyrannical governments last night bernie
sanders of course did that as well
Bernie over the past few days has been
asked about his past support of Fidel
Castro what does he do he doubles down
again last night what I said is what
Barack Obama said in terms of Cuba that
Cuba made progress on
education yes I think really really
[Applause]
brocco bombers ideas they made open
great progress on educations making
health care there is no way to spin
Fidel Castro to be a good guy for the
vast majority of the American electorate
all right it might work for Bernie
Sanders his base who don't don't know
much about history but it's not gonna
work for the majority of the American
electorate it's gonna kill him in
Florida which is why all the Republicans
are hoping that Bernie Sanders gets the
nomination now he he just can't help
himself because he really believes this
stuff I mean he Bernie has been a
revolutionary for a very very long time
as we'll see in one of his manifestos
from 40 years ago in just a second just
this very week I think Bernie Sanders
criticized Bibi Netanyahu's government
in Israel is bigoted racist terrible
awful and he praised and lauded Fidel
Castro's dictatorship in Cuba tells you
everything you need to know about that
guy's foreign policy then Bernie had a
another terrible hit he steps in it
again when he said that he has a jobs
plan for minorities I kid you not his
jobs plan for minorities is to legalize
drugs so that minorities in particular
can legally sell drugs and I'll tell you
what else we're gonna do we're gonna
provide help to the african-american
Latino Native American community to
start businesses to sell legal marijuana
rather than let a few corporations
control the legalize marijuana Marcos is
something that if you scripted it for
Larry David on Saturday and I live they
would say no no that's too far it's so
tone-deaf it's so offensive to say yeah
well the only way we're gonna get black
and Hispanic people to hold down jobs is
if we legalize drugs because look all
they all those guys can do is sell drugs
right so we're just gonna legalize drugs
and then they'll do it legally are you
kidding me could you imagine if Donald
Trump had said that they'd impeach him
for it but Bernie Sanders says admit
sort of passes by it sort of just one of
those cute quirks of burny burny really
just on the minute-by-minute play of the
debate had a pretty bad night he ended
up getting booed when he went back for
the seventh or eighth time to his
favorite line about the billionaires and
the no longer the millionaires because
he's a millionaire so he goes and he has
sales the billionaires again it's a big
round of boos from the audience
bird has a solid and strong and
enthusiastic base of support problem is
they're all billionaires still Bernie
won because nobody did any good for
themselves Pete had an OK night
Bloomberg did a lot better than he did
last time but last time he did terribly
but nobody really did that much good and
Elizabeth Warren pretty much admitted
this right off the top when she came out
there as part of her strategy to
ingratiate herself to the Bernie
progressives she actually admitted that
Bernie's winning the race and she even
complimented him is that Bernie is
winning right now because the Democratic
Party is a progressive party and
progressive ideas are popular ideas even
if there are a lot of people on this
stage who don't want to say so you know
but Bernie and I agree on a lot of
things but I think I would make a better
president than Bernie and the reason for
that is that getting a progressive
agenda enacted is going to be really
hard and it's gonna take someone who
digs into the details to make it happen
this is a bad idea I know why she did it
I mean she's she's realizing that there
aren't that many paths left to her in
the race and so she's just saying please
Bernie voters please I really like you I
really like you just come on over to me
and leave your man Bernie it's not gonna
work you can't out Bernie Bernie you
can't do it you can't out Trump Trump a
lot of candidates tried to do that last
time in the 2016 race it doesn't work
you remember when Marco Rubio decided
because he was losing Trump's poll
numbers were winning but he was just
gonna go out there and do a Trump
impression so he went out and did
basically a round of insult comedy made
fun of Donald Trump's hands suggested
that other body parts were small and it
just it doesn't land you know you've the
voters can smell this
they can sense it when you're being
inauthentic or what you're being
flattering or ingratiating and it
doesn't work especially for someone as
unconventional as Donald Trump or a
candidate as radical as Bernie Sanders
she's not gonna out Bernie Bernie and
she's probably gonna lose and Bernie is
probably going to win it cuz even though
he did terribly at the debate last night
he actually won it because nobody else
did well either Bernie Sanders may be
the guy and if Bernie Sanders is the guy
it's time to start taking a closer look
at what this guy believes because unlike
say President Trump
President Trump is a guy who entered
politics without a totally hardened
ideological view right his view of
politics was I can do it I'm really good
at fixing things I'm gonna fix things
but he's not an ideologue okay he wasn't
he's not a Marxist he's not a
libertarian he's not he hasn't like
studied the intricacies of ideology
Bernie Sanders has and he's written
about it and what he's written about it
is creepy and weird he there a lot of
people have talked about Bernie Sanders
as 1972 rape essay where he talks about
rape so he talks about how men fantasize
about abusing women and how women
fantasize about being abused that is not
even the creepiest thing he's ever
written about sex he's written something
far creepier which the Bloomberg
campaign dug up it's called the
revolution is life versus death this is
from 1969 we will analyze it because I
don't think anybody's talking about it
and it tells you a lot not just about
Bernie but about leftism we'll get to
that in a second first I've got to tell
you how I get over hangovers now and
what most people would use this for is
to hydrate after being athletic you know
doing some sporting event that obviously
that's not what I do
liquid IV liquid IVs cellular transport
technology delivers an optional ratio of
nutrients for more efficient uptake so
if you're a good person who's got your
whole life in order you could use this
in the morning I mean it's it's like you
get that energy like you would from a
cup of coffee but you don't get the
crash or you'd use it after you go on a
long run or something me not me after I
go out for a couple coca-cola's with the
boys come back it's real
good way to hydrate enhanced rapid
absorption into the bloodstream gives
you a lasting energy boost fast liquid
IV can power your morning's liquid IV
can fuel long days at the office and it
can provide a boost for tough workouts
so I'm told
clean ingredients non GMO vegan of free
of gluten dairy and soy all that stuff
that I don't even understand all that
terrible stuff that's not good for you
they take it out of there it's really
great it's convenient TSA friendly which
is important if you travel a lot
single-serving packets perfect for
travel I love it everyone loves it at
the office you got to check it out get
25% off when you go to liquid IV comm
and use the code Knowles kind of wles at
checkout 25% off anything you order on
liquid IVs website liquid IV comm enter
promo code Knowles to save 25% and get
better hydration and energy liquid IV
comm promo code Knowles don't wait start
fueling your adventures today so we had
heard about this we had heard about this
1972 rape essay a Hillary Clinton
brought this up in 2016 he talks about
you know all these rape fantasies and
things it's a creepy article I mean he
even refers to 13 year olds having sex
it's weird but in Bernie's defense the
point of the article is to describe how
sex has gone wrong because of our evil
society so he's not actually defending
rape or something I mean I think that's
an unfair attack however the essay is
important and another essay that he
wrote about sex is even more important
because it does tell us a lot about his
not just his views on sex but his views
on radical politics this essay called
the Revolutionists life versus death was
published in the Vermont Freeman in
November 1969 this is when Bernie
Sanders was 28 years old okay he wasn't
a freshman in college here alright
everybody writes stupid things when
they're freshmen in college he was 28
this guy's pushing 30 when he wrote this
his views were pretty well-formed at
this point he still had never held down
a job in his life but he had thought a
lot about his vision of the world I
guess he still hasn't really held down a
job
other than working for the government
for his old life
what's interesting about this piece is
this is the revolutionary manifesto that
he wrote it's about politics it's about
government it's about economics but for
some reason sex is at the center of it
and I noticed this is true a lot with
the left at the centre of their
revolutionary craziness very often it
boils down to sex why is that Bernie
actually explains it in this essay we
will get to that in a second first I've
got to say goodbye to Facebook and at
YouTube we got a few things to tell you
about they're very exciting next Tuesday
Super Tuesday daily wire backstage is
gonna be with you the whole time so
block out your whole night we're gonna
be doing it I'll probably at least have
three or four cigars and be very
inebriated by the end of it because of
how long that night is going to go so
check that out Matt Walsh has a new book
out which is superb it's called Church
of cowards a wake-up call for complacent
Christians you can get it right now in
Amazon Barnes and Noble all over the
place it's a really important topic you
know there are Christians being martyred
in the Middle East most Christians in
the United States are unwilling to even
put down their smartphones for a few
minutes so check it out Church of
cowards by Matt Walsh and by the way
leap day is coming up leap day happens
but once every four years you should go
and be ready because there's gonna be a
very exciting deal that happens at the
Daily wire on leap day so set your
calendars be ready waiting on the edge
of your seat head on over to Daley wire
calm right now we'll be right back with
a lot more
all right the revolution is life versus
death it begins by Bernard Sanders Mr
Sanders who has written several other
thoughtful pieces for the Freeman lives
in Greensboro Bend from which vantage
point he takes a penetrating look at the
world around him you see penetrating
that is a pun right there penetrating
from the very beginning from what the
editors threw in there the piece begins
are a couple paragraphs there you know
doesn't say very much these manifestos
always get a little bit windy then he
goes on death and some people actually
wonder why young people rebel why there
is a revolution taking place lies lies
lies invasion napalm torture bombings
annihilation of whole villages body
counts and more lies in defense of
Liberty against communist aggression to
protect American interests empty phrases
dead words spoken by dead people lies
democracy is a United States Congress
composed of millionaires and state
legislatures controlled by lobbyists now
I know that Bernie's regretting that
line right now because he is one of the
millionaire's who's in Congress so
probably didn't see that one coming he
didn't think that his future earnings
potential was so great what he's saying
is he doesn't believe in Liberty what
he's saying is he doesn't oppose
communism what he's saying is he doesn't
support American interests and what he's
saying is he doesn't believe in
democracy in America in a phrase he's
saying he doesn't believe in America
it's all a lie they're all phonies he's
like holding Caulfield in Catcher in the
Rye that annoying kid in that annoying
book it's this hyper cynicism that is
fashionable among idiot teenagers before
their brains fully developed
Bernie wrote this at 28 it wasn't 15 or
something
Bernie has always been a late bloomer
right he didn't get a job until he was
40 he didn't have a major political
career until he was 75 a late bloomer
maybe hasn't bloomed at all
actually maybe the reason that his
career is taking off now is because our
culture has just finally degraded itself
to his level he goes on a revolution is
taking place life is fighting against
strangulation and death and life will
win life is young at any age
alive open and non fearing pause I
believe by the by non fearing what he
means is unafraid I don't know if non
fearing is some like cool hip speak or
he just didn't have a great command of
the English language but he goes on life
can take his clothes off and be naked
with friends hmm he or she has nothing
to hide there is nothing prettier than
the unclothed human body in Miami the
American Legion sponsors a rally for
decency even Jackie Gleason attends Jim
Morrison of the doors is arrested for
giving a lewd performance he is immoral
okay so now this is the first place
where it starts to transition into
something about sex I thought we were
talking about politics and revolution
all of a sudden we're talking about the
naked human body and lewd performances
and why that's not really immoral this
is a common thread among leftist
radicals this goes all the way back to
Rousseau who is you know this we're
talking 250 years ago now the kind of
proto radical intellectual type this
connection between nakedness and the
truth you think about the naked truth
right we're gonna take away all this all
the coverings and we're gonna get get to
the truth there's this utopian dream
that we have to get rid of artificial
things are you hear this a lot with the
crunchy earthy people on the left
especially if we just go back to nature
everything will be really really great
that's the idea now I don't think that's
true I don't think we will everything
will be really great when we go back to
nature but Bernie explains how and when
he explains how this is when it gets
really pervy okay he says quote because
they have been good little children and
because of the judge this year is
liberal daddy is going to allow everyone
who is over 18 to see I am curious
yellow which was a porno film from the
60s yes you can see naked people and
even sexual intercourse
right in your local movie theater and
300,000 people over 18 lined up like
good little girls and boys and saw it
yes son age 90 that's how other people
do it in Vermont at a State Beach a
mother is reprimanded by Authority for
allowing her six-month-old daughter to
go without her diapers on now if
children go around naked they're liable
to see each other's sexual organs and
maybe even touch them terrible thing if
we bring children up like this it will
probably ruin the whole pornography
business not to mention the large
segment of the general economy which
makes its money by playing on people's
sexual frustrations the revolution is
coming and it is a very beautiful
revolution it is beautiful because in
its deepest sense it is quiet gentle and
all pervasive it knows all right a lot
of creepiness to unpacked here right so
what he's saying is he's kind of mocking
liberal culture which has pornography
which it says is immoral but every so
often you get to see it and he's he's
criticizing that only people over 18 get
to see the pornography he's what he's
criticizing this whole time is that we
are not introducing children to sex this
is part of a broader theme that was
going on on the left in the 60s and 70s
which is about introducing sex to
children by acknowledging children as
sexual creatures all right that this is
not some right-wing conspiracy theory
you can read it right here in in Joe Joe
Biden that was a Freudian slip in Bernie
Sanders's own words
he keeps going back to how crazy it is
that only people over 18 get to do this
stuff right
it gets overtly sexual and the image of
children gets overtly sexual he blames
clothing by going back to nakedness he
blames clothing which is a symbol for
our repressed traditional capitalist
civilization he blames that for sexual
dysfunction which is symptomatic of our
broader social dysfunction so the
clothing is the kind of symbol of why
everything goes wrong in our society and
then he suggests that the cure to sexual
dysfunction is for kids to run around
naked and this is the crucial part to
engage in sexual acts with each other
what he is literally saying in this
essay is that if we were all to sexually
molest each other as children we
wouldn't row up with sexual and social
pathologies all right the whole thing
this whole essay has been crazy up until
this point but now we see it most
clearly because we all know that people
who were molested as children have much
much more trouble later in life than
those who were not it doesn't solve
social pathologies it creates them but
Bernie's bad sex advice is not just for
children you know what he's what he's
partaking of is this vision of the world
which comes from Freud which is that
we've just got all these sexual
frustrations and we're like a steam
engine and we've this we've got to let
the steam out we got to let the pressure
out because either we can't repress
anything and so we've just got to do
whatever we want we've got to follow any
desire that we have any lust that we
have whether it's disordered or not very
popular idea in the late 60s turns out
it was completely wrong and it's led to
absolute cultural chaos and and personal
destruction but that was the idea okay
and and it's not just for the kids it's
for the adults too
he says the revolution comes when two
strangers smile at each other when a
father refuses to send his child to
school because schools destroy children
when a communist started and people
begin to trust each other
when a young man refuses to go to war
and when a girl pushes aside all that
her mother has taught her and accepts
her boyfriends love now before we get
into this craziness
the communing sample is funny one
because virtually every comm unit
history has failed but it's especially
funny here because two years after this
essay was written Bernie Sanders got
kicked off of a commune for being too
lazy do you do you know how lazy you
have to be to be kicked off of a hippie
commune like you'd like immobile like
can't lift your arm kind of lazy so
that's just a funny irony that we can
only see now with in hindsight because
at this time this was right before
Bernie got kicked off but notice that
last line that last line there is key
when a girl pushes aside all that her
mother has taught and accepts her
boyfriends love
let's him let's him do what he wants
that accepts your boyfriend's love how
has that worked out
also in hindsight we can test that
theory against reality
since the sexual revolution of the
1960's most young women have taken
Bernie's advice and the advice of the
left generally and it has made them in
particular miserable rates of STDs have
skyrocketed abortion rates have
skyrocketed depression anxiety stress
all have skyrocketed people who are
soaked on psych drugs because they're so
depressed skyrocketed loneliness major
epidemic loneliness you can directly tie
to this kind of stupid advice me too
abuses we just saw Harvey Weinstein get
sentenced to prison yesterday me too
gotten worse and worse and worse even
worse than it was before and women's
happiness has plummeted both in absolute
terms and relative to men according to
every study we have on the subject you
know the the line that these radicals
always use is they say we've never tried
my ideas before real socialism's never
been tried or real revolutions never
been tried it has obviously it's been
tried in other places around the world
but these ideas these cultural ideas
have been tried in the United States and
they've failed in the historical record
is very clear
why do revolutionary ideologies always
seem to revolve around sex
250 300 years back Rousseau absent Karl
Marx jean-paul Sartre all of these
radicals these radical intellectuals had
bizarre and creepy attitudes toward sex
modern leftism is completely obsessed
with sex sex education is one of their
top issues abortion on demand they just
had another vote on it yesterday
wouldn't even a vote to give medical
care to a baby who survived an abortion
that's how obsessed there with abortion
redefining marriage Buddha judge having
a nine year old boy come out as
homosexual at a campaign rally on
national television and then telling him
that his identity is merely the sum
total of his sexual desires it is
weird it is very creepy and it's
effective that's why they do it that's
why that's why even when they're talking
about economics somehow sex gets into it
even when they're talking about very
about politics about systems of
government somehow sex always gets into
it the reason for that is that sex is
our most basic passion so in Genesis for
instance and Gilgamesh right
civilization begins with sex all these
stories about how humanity began people
are easily manipulated by sex sex has to
play an important role in any worldview
and it also plays an important role in
revolutionary politics because if you
can harness person's sexual passions you
can make them less rational and you can
make them more malleable you can twist
them that's that's why Bernie Sanders is
so obsessed with sex I want to get to
some more creepy sex stuff cNN has just
redefined newborn babies I can't I can't
leave today without getting to this cNN
has redefined newborn babies as fetuses
that are born headline to abortion
restriction bills that forced forced
tough votes for vulnerable senators fail
in the Senate quote the second bill to
be considered Tuesday is the born alive
abortion survivors Protection Act
sponsored by Republican senator Ben
Sasse of Nebraska that would require
abortion providers to work to preserve
the health and life the life and health
of a fetus that was born following an
attempted abortion as they would for a
newborn baby or face up to five years in
prison so they have to use the same
measures that they would use on a
newborn baby as they would use for a
newborn baby except wait a second it
can't be a newborn baby because you have
to save newborn babies and we want to
kill this baby so this guy can't be it's
got to be a fetus that was born the prop
this poses a major problem for the PC
euphemism game here what is a fetus
fetus is the Latin word for offspring
that's where we get the word fetus from
fate ruse means offspring in modern
terms that left has defined fetus to
mean an unborn baby or a preborn baby
that's all it means once the baby is
outside of the mother it's a baby but
when it's inside the mother it's a fetus
so when a fetus is born by the left's
own definition it ceases to be a fetus
and it becomes a baby now this is
difficult if a baby survives an abortion
and which in many cases the baby is just
killed or denied medical care and so Ben
Sasse and these Senate Republicans are
calling attention to this and saying
wait a second what happens when the baby
survives you got to give it medical care
trouble is it becomes a baby according
to the left once it leaves the mother
but if it's a baby you can't kill it but
if a baby and a fetus are the same thing
then it's a distinction without a
difference so if you can't kill the baby
may be sure to kill the fetus either
yikes Democrats blocked the bill of
course they did they needed 60 votes in
the Senate to get it over procedural
hurdles and the Democrats blocked it
only Democrats Bob Casey Doug Jones and
Joe Manchin these are kind of red-state
more conservative Democrats on a few
issues they were the only ones who voted
to give medical care to newborn babies
whose mothers didn't want them every
other Democrat voted against it so what
every other Democrat is saying is that
we don't have a natural right to life
there's no human right to life whatever
phrase they want to use the only thing
that confers life is being wanted by
your mother so if your mother doesn't
want you one day your right to life is
gone anybody can kill you it's free game
this is this is evil stuff Pete Buddha
judge likes to point out that God
doesn't belong to a political party God
definitely doesn't belong to this
political party tell you that I don't
make bold theological declarations
usually about these kind of things
pretty sure I can make that one there
can be a legitimate disagreement among
Christians on a number of political
issues there cannot be a legitimate
disagreement about this okay some issues
no disagreement is permitted this is one
of them if you're a Christian you cannot
vote for a Democrat who supports this
I guess this gets to the point of Matt
Walsh's book which is in bookstores now
you can't do it the Catholic Church is
very clear on this and I know a lot of
other Christian denominations are very
clear on this you cannot do it if you
support this kind of stuff in your
Catholic
you can't even receive Communion you
should you should go confess your sin
before you do it that's according to the
church same goes for socialism by the
way Catholic Church very clear on
socialism you cannot be a Catholic in a
socialist and yet so many Christians
today don't want to talk about this
they're so afraid of being involved in
politics they say well no maybe you can
really you can support slaughtering
babies after they've been born and you
can support all these things and still
be Christian no you can't two marks
against the Democrats here who in
previous years played down their
socialism played down their abortion
extremism so there could be a legitimate
debate you can't do it now
if you're Catholic if you call yourself
Christian at all and you support these
things you're doing something very very
wrong
and you should stop it by the way it
doesn't look like the Democratic Party
is going to move to the right anytime
soon okay
this is Bernie Sanders's party now
there's a story that came out who knows
if it's true that Bernie wanted to
primary Barack Obama in 2012 all right
between those two the Obama Democratic
Party which was already pretty radical
and the Sanders Democratic Party we are
now in Sanders territory and you got to
pick a side pick up what side you want
to be on the side of hmm hey maybe we
should grow the economy and not focus on
all this weird creepy stuff or the side
of bizarre sexual manifestos and killing
newborn babies and taking away all your
property and socialism doesn't seem like
a hard choice for me but you know you
got to make your own decision that's our
show there's a lot more to get to by the
way I'm in DC right now is you might be
able to tell if you're watching this and
so we're gonna be at CPAC with verdict
senator Ted Cruz and I will be there
doing an event tomorrow so if you're in
DC come on out it'll be a lot of fun
otherwise in the meantime get your mail
bags questions in I'm Michael Knowles
this is the Michael Nolt show see you
tomorrow
[Music]
the Michael Nolt show is produced by Ben
Davies and directed by Mike joiner
executive producer Jeremy Boren
supervising producers Mathis Glover and
Robert Sterling technical producer
Austin Stephens assistant director hovel
Woodhouse key editor and associate
producer Danny D'Amico audio mixer Robin
Fenderson hair and makeup nikka Geneva
production assistant Ryan love the
Michael Noel's show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 20 on
the Matt Walsh oh we're not just
discussing politics we're talking
culture faith family all of the things
that are really important to you so come
join the conversation
you